what's the hardest part of making a
movie and why hmm
that's a that's interesting one I think
the hardest part about making a film is
the logistics sometimes it's those
unknowable things that you have no
control over and being able to it
doesn't matter if it's a hundred million
dollar movie or two hundred thousand
dollar feature there's always gonna be
things that come up where you don't have
control over them right so and that's
just the nature of what we do is we're
taking a camera and we're pointing it at
real people in real situations and
things in real life kind of always like
things happen right I mean you know this
actor isn't available or they're in the
you know thing going on the lights not
working the Sun is setting we're losing
our light the sound isn't what we felt
like there's loud sounds here so there's
these unknowable things that are always
coming at you as a director and you have
to be able to filter out the ones that
are gonna require your attention and the
ones that you have to kind of just move
on from so I think that's what that
that's one of those things that you
can't really learn you have to
experience and kind of have that sort of
thing in your belt where this situation
has happened to you before where the Sun
is setting and you have five shots to
get on your shot list and crap okay how
do we get this scene in one shot now
because the Sun is setting and that's
when you're thinking as an editor and
you're saying okay the previous scene we
did this and there was a shot where a
character walk from here to here you
know what I don't really need to get
that transition moment let's just go
straight into him he's in the room and
it's coming what it's being able to be
nimble on your feet and make those
adjustments and make those cuts in your
head so that you don't lose your whole
day so that you know and the previous
just come up to you and say did you get
the scene you can say confidently we got
the scene it cuts together it works is
that we're the sort of monk like
stoicism comes into play because like
that I'm sure that that sounds like
could panic to you either way on that
one yeah definitely those are those
situations where you have to not let the
outside distractions kind of pull you
away from what your goal is as a
director which is you got to sit behind
the monitor and this is one word of
advice I got when I was in film school
was ultimately the director is the ideal
audience for a film so when they're
sitting behind that monitor or they're
sitting next to the camera watching the
actor is looking at the scene got to
look at it as the perspective of an
ideal audience member and be like that
worked or that's gonna require one more
or how is that gonna cut to the next
thing right as a storyteller you're kind
of putting yourself in that position and
you're looking at it from that
perspective so being able to just turn
off everything around you all the noise
and just being able to for that for that
moment where you call action and cut
that little in between just being able
to look at it as an audience remember
that ideal audience member and just
taking it all in I think is critical to
being able to tell your story
you